before because desantis and um i i've
been told as his wife they're very savvy
with what's happening culturally right
and on social media great team and so i
look at that and i'm like
could you imagine how desantis would
handle the press
look they're going to smear them they're
going to try and destroy the same as
they did with trump but he's just better
at it
and and to your point about like a daily
youtube video that's something i could
imagine a desantis administration
actually doing not necessarily that way
but doing something more active on
social media for directly connecting
with people i think the issue with trump
is that
politically he's in the right place for
so many americans but he's just very old
and he was getting bad advice i wonder
if desantis would be a lot better with
the media because they've never liked
him whereas trump he had this long spell
where you know he was on the apprentice
and he was just big and rich and famous
larger than life personality and they
they liked him they ate it up they wrote
all kinds of stuff about him even before
he was running for president i remember
melania trump being on the cover of some
dumb magazine when she got married to
him with her glorious dress and i was
like never again would we see this once
he got elected and that has to sting
especially for a guy with an ego like
that but i think desantis would get it
in the bag it will be really awesome
though if trump wins in 2024
and then that means he wins with the
with the help of people who voted for
biden in 2020 yeah just to prove a point
yeah just to be like hey all those
people yeah yeah biden was bad be like
obama voters yeah you know but but real
quick that also means some of these
people are going to refuse to vote for
trump out of their personal ego
so they might be like i can't do that i
can't have been that guy who was like
trump is is is worse than hitler and now
come crawling back to him i refuse i
will never admit that
you get a desantis and they'll be like
oh well i mean you know i was always
against biden and desantis is better so
yeah the other thing that makes me
nervous about desantis though is that i
think there there have been a lot of
more
establishmenty and never trumpy type
people who are 100 on board with
desantis
and that makes me a little bit nervous
because i worry that people who were
really on board with trump particularly
the people who moved over from the
democratic party the obama voters who
would see that in as a bit of a betrayal
like why am i supporting the same guy
that these people support and i wouldn't
want to jump away from trump too quickly
because i think a lot of trump
supporters did have a valid reason
for liking him in particular even over
other people who support some of the
same policies because he really was a
trail blazer for the republican party in
terms of a lot of those more populist
nationalistic policies and also just
speaking the way that he did
i know a lot of people who said i've
never heard a politician
talk the way that i talk like at the
shop with my
co-workers or
in the locker room with my friends
things like that
and that cult of personality is
i mean like it or not really important
politics downside of that i agree i like
the way he talked like well i mean he
said some crass stuff but i like that he
was honest and like just off the cuff
and then it's day one he started reading
speeches he'd come on tv and he'd be
talking like this and like that and like
that's not trump that's not donald trump
that's not how he talks and it was so he
just just just just got
filed into the machine it felt like day
one he had john bolton on staff and like
i don't i don't know i don't want round
two
not right away bolton but uh
i think it was what sheldon adelson
you know told them trump to do it and
trump was like okay and i i guess my
understanding is he legitimately thought
it was going to be a good idea that just
goes to show that trump really did not
know what to expect when it came to the
school yeah he had reince priebus as his
chief of staff i would imagine if you
were going to do it and do it right for
real you'd have to have your own way of
doing it and there'll be tons of people
being like no don't do it that way no we
got to stop him and you'll be like gone
and away from them they can't even find
you because you're doing it the way you
want to do it and what i understand is
there was a plan for the second term to
root out a lot of the people who were
undermining trump so like john mcentee
was placed in charge of personnel uh
towards the last year and he was
basically compiling like a hit list of
employees that were not loyal and needed
to get the hell out
and yeah it was too late and like amanda
milius was in the trump administration
she's spoken about um
changing federal rules so that you can
fire uh non-political appointees more
easily and things like that
so i mean there's a lot of ways that
this could be done better i just hope
that
if trump were to run again that he would
be listening to the right people this
time around and make those decisions
more wisely i think we do another trump
2024 we do another trump uh run with
2024 and then after trump you get to
sanders yeah it's like inevitable yeah i
mean do you think that we can handle
that the country can
but having a decentralized leader now
isn't
any good either well he's a centralized
authority
he gets all the rules go through him no
no actually what i mean is that he's not
the head honcho decision maker of his
administration i i disagree and i think
this actually plays into ian's point
biden is and he's insane because his
brain has deteriorated to this point
but i think look kamala harris she's 11
staffers have quit on her
she is just sitting there spinning in
circles confused and blabbering making
no sense
there's there's no real leadership in
this administration at all i genuinely
think that there are
there's a combination of two things
people exploiting the opportunity and
just doing what they want because
biden's out of it and people who are
like what should we do joe and joe's
like you know you get your next role
wrestling you know and
you gotta get better for the war crimes
and then and then he gets up and he goes
get it done and he walks out and they're
like i don't know what next now wrestle
means what do i do
i i legit think that um
you know some people believe that he's a
puppet and i'm like no if he was a
puppet there would be a plan
like if somebody was in charge there
would be a cohesive string of events do
you think it's possible though that
there's more than one person directly
underneath biden that is that are
competing for
oh yeah decision making ability like ron
clay
yes but that's that's kind of my point
too that they're still beholden to biden
in a certain way and they're they're
they're
you know
biden is a central authority and as a
nexenel resident
and whatever garbled word garbage he
said president
they're they're they're unable to pull
the trigger on things without the
president's approval and the president
is just basically a walking corpse at
this point so what that does is when the
power is centralized in biden and biden
can't speak words right
then
the whole system is just shaking like a
rickety bridge on the verge of snapping
i disagree with the idea that trump is a
cult leader or a cult of personality
trump is just a leader why and he came
out and he said
these are problems and a bunch of
americans were like we agree
no one's dealing with those things and
so they said i'll vote for you i meant
more in the general sense of the way our
system's structured that we vote for our
hero that our popularity contest to put
someone in supreme power is like a cult
it's like a american we call it the
government american government but it's
a cult where we choose our leader and
then we're all like ah we're all
surrounding the leaders
but it's not your name
congress senate the supreme court there
they're important i mean the executive
doesn't have as much power as people
think but i think what's interesting
about trump is that it was almost the
opposite of a popularity contest because
people almost voted for him because he
was unpopular
like
i don't think trump was the guy that
i mean if you go back to like the bush
election people were like i'd rather
have a beer with bush than carrie for
example is that really the case with
donald trump like i don't know i think a
lot of people held their nose and voted
for trump and i agree it was kind of the
opposite of a popularity contest in that
way well they
i i i
it was like
i guess that's right i mean it was it
was almost like despite his personality
we move over him because we like these
particular things where we like the
waste but name recognition i was at the
airport i was at a airport i think i was
in texas
and i went to the lounge at the bar and
there was a woman and i asked if she
like i asked her to turn off cnn or
something and put on fox
and then she said something about you
know i can't stand it we started talking
a little bit there's a guy sitting to my
left and then all of a sudden we were
all talking about politics she told me
that she was like look i was for bernie
so i didn't like any of these people
biden's terrible and i'm like here here
i felt that way in 2016 but i think
trump at least did stuff we've never
seen before or at least in my generation
the guy to my left chimes in and he goes
oh i voted for trump and i'll vote for
him again but i wouldn't invite him to
my house for dinner and then we all
laughed and i was like
that's kind of the way i think a lot of
people felt about it you know he was
like he's a good president but he's kind
of a dick and i'm like yeah yeah a lot a
lot of people were like we recognize the
problem of trump but
and that's why
the left went so hard on the suburban
women vote in 2020 because they really
wanted to emphasize trump's personality
defects
what i think the trump administration or
camp campaign rather did wrong in their
response was they tried to
win over like white liberal wine moms by
talking about criminal justice reform
and
like everything that they're doing for
opportunity zones when they should have
been talking about how
like trump could stop the riots before
they got to your neighborhood like they
they misunderstood the solution to what
the left was telling people about
trump's personality and he could have
leveraged that i think in a much more
effective way on the campaign trail but
and out so uh playing into your point
ian about cult leaders and centralized
authority i think if you look at one of
the most important issues in the culture
war gun rights you can see that
centralization doesn't have anything to
do with its culture
georgia is about to sign into law
constitutional carry which will make it
the 25th state and i want to i want to
state for the record a correction
because i was right
when i was on joe rogan's show in
november
i said
that i said i think majority of the
country is constitutional carry and then
joe was like no no that can't be right
and i was like yeah i'm pretty sure
and then jamie pulled looked it up and
it said 13 states and i went only 13
doesn't sound right right that was a
very old number it was 24 i believe it
was 24 at the time
24 states have it had it it may have
been 21 at the time because in the past
four months there's been a wave
but 21 better than 13. so i was wrong
but not that wrong and i want to make
sure that everybody knows this
uh georgia
is about to sign into law constitutional
carry ron desantis is uh is talking
about a special legislative session
which may include constitutional care
which means 26 states
permit lists conceal and open carry you
walk in you're a resident some of these
states are constitutional carry i think
i think constitutional carry applies to
non-residents as well at a certain age
limit it's like 21. that means you can
if if you're in texas and this and you
know and then i think
louisiana doesn't have it but uh if you
go from georgia to say mississippi and
they're both constitutional care you
don't got to worry about crossing that
border yeah this is a huge cultural
change in victory showing the sentiment
of the american people that the federal
politicians don't matter when when
regular people vote for state reps for
state senators for local politicians
your state can do right
seeing all that happen shows just how
important it is
that we we utilize and pay attention to
our decentralized political system and
don't stay heavily focused on just trump
winning that is to say good vote for
trump in 2024 if that's what you want
but make sure you're voting in the
primaries right now
2022 midterms are coming up and it's not
gonna matter if people set up the
primaries because you're gonna get a
whole bunch of rhinos neocons
establishment uniparty garbage
but yeah i the the the constitutional
carry thing has me super excited yeah
yeah me too i mean i'm a gun owner
myself um well actually i recently lost
them on a boating accident it was very
tragic but you know i love guns um grew
up with guns
and like i'm a huge proponent of maybe
having classes in school where students
can learn gun safety i think that would
go a long way towards making people feel
more comfortable with gun culture if
they didn't grow up with it did you did
you see you i think it was like alaska
or something yeah they were doing
airsoft training i think that is awesome
i mean
what no no no it's terrible why those
kids should be outside with 22s okay all
right you got me they shouldn't be using
airsoft in a gym
they should be outside with 10 22's and
they should be getting proper
instruction it'd be fantastic i mean i
think that uh you would see a a huge
reduction in things like accidental gun
deaths or
i don't know like some of these other
statistics that the left likes to throw
out to make people afraid of guns if you
just raise people to understand that
they are a tool that needs to be treated
with very specific safety regulations
and the way that you you behave with a
gun
and they're not toys to be played with
and they're not anything to be afraid of
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there